welcome back to the three Muslims before
we jump right into it on her bro you
were a non-muslim Once Upon a Time
weren't you
Once Upon a Time and Allah Mubarak Allah
guided you ain't that right
when you were non-muslim did you
celebrate Halloween
yes trick-or-treating it's like
normalized in our society isn't it a lot
of people have been flooding the DMS is
it permissible as a notch should I let
my kids go trick-or-treating let's see
what Sheikh uthman even farrukh has to
say if you missed our episodes we'll
share with mon inshallah make sure you
catch them we have many that we have
done a lot of gems in them but let's see
what he has to say is
question we get a lot is regarding
Halloween is it Halal is it haram can
you give out candy can you still go
through a celebration even if you don't
believe in it but before we can answer
any of that we have to look at the roots
of any celebration anything new historic
research and then we turn to a book
published by the National Geographic
society called an uncommon history of
common things it's from a non-biased
perspective it's not a Muslim
perspective it's not a Christian
perspective just historic research of
what we have as common practices today
in it they write about Halloween now
this was of the Celtics of Ireland took
this as a sacred ritual called Samhain
honoring samhan the Lord of death
in It On All Hallows Eve which was what
is Halloween today October 31st
supposedly fairies and Mortals were in
closest contacts with the spirit world
and Spirits were not beloved to people
they were harmful to people so people
would make themselves as demons and
goblins wearing animal skins and heads
and made noisy processions to put away
the spirits Druid priests use this as a
religious Festival
it was intended to drive away evil
spirits and to be away from those that
were recently dead after the Harvest
sacrifices were made including animal
and human sacrifices and fortunes were
told and each family carried home a
torch with fire to tell the fortunes
that were to come
Christians after Conquering the area
banned the practice as a pagan devil
worshiping Festival
when we look at this historic routes
from a Satan worshiping devil worshiping
Druid bases a religious Festival on the
31st of October
than any Muslim Christian or Jew who
follows their faith should not
participate in such a festival its roots
and its current practices of dressing up
as goblins and devils and things is
rooted in a religious Festival
celebrating the Lord of death somehow
knowing the prophets
whoever tries to emulate or resemble a
people he is from them and in sahil
bukhari the prophet sallallahu alaihi
sallam told us that
um
that a person would be with the whom he
loves on the day of judgment imagine
being raised on the day of judgment with
those Celtic Druids those worshipers of
shaytan those people who who followed
these practices including human
sacrifices on these days
so as a Muslim as a Christian or Jew we
should not participate not by changing
its name not by having drunk or treat by
putting cards or trying to do any of
these things we should do away with such
a practice and follow those celebrations
that our prophet sallallahu alaihi and
let me sum this up for anyone that
missed that
um this is answered by Sheikh Ibrahim
Desai from uh this is in Islam QA but
before we go into that the people that
say otherwise bro are just the people of
desires bro these are the same people
that are going to be like birthdays are
okay you know because it's just it's
just birthdays everyone does it you know
what I mean but when you really look
back to the history things aren't as a
theme so uh this is not the first thing
test before we discuss the
impermissibility of Halloween we'd like
to give a brief background to facilitate
the readers kind of just summarizes
origin of Halloween can be traced to an
ancient Pagan Festival known as Samhain
celebrated by Celtic people over 2 000
Years Ago by the 9th century the
influence of Christianity had spread
into the South glance was widely
believed today the church was attempting
to replace the Celtic Festival of the
Dead with a related but
church-sanctioned holiday
so David's guy an American cultural
historian States it was a calculated
move on the parts of the church to bring
more people into the fold of
Christianity trick-or-treating one of
the main activities uh dates back to
souling where poor people would visit
the houses of wealthier families and
receive pastries called Soul cakes
sounds like trick-or-treating in
exchange for a promise to pray for the
souls of the homeowners dead relatives
the practice was later Taken up by
children who would go from door to door
asking for gifts such as food money and
Ill
the early Celts would also dress up in
mass and costumes symbolizing the evil
spirits in an attempt to please them
the costumes were also used in an effort
to blend in with the evil spirits as to
not be singled out and haunted for the
coming year
Halloween is also a billion dollar
holiday second only to Christmas
according to a survey conducted by the
NRF the total spending for Halloween
just in 2016. this was this was years
ago bro this was like six years ago
um but in 2016 was reaching 8.4 billion
dollars
this is just for Halloween us consumers
are expected to spend an average of 82
dollars every single year
on Halloween
decorations candy whatever Islam is not
the only religion which rejects this
holiday it is opposed to by Jehovah's
Witnesses Jews and Hindus although we do
not require validation from other
religions their religion their rejection
of this holiday also proves just how
exact religious it is
um so therefore he concludes celebrating
Halloween in any form is impermissible
and against the teachings of Islam
affirmated
he mentioned
those that imitate any people are among
them
I think that is clear oh no what do you
think
he's crazy dude because it's such a
normalized thing
you know like when I was a kid I should
dress up as a Pokemon
like I literally should dress up as a
Charmander so I thought it was crazy
when people were sort of gave me the
nickname of Charizard because I was
literally Charmander when I was a little
kid that was my favorite Pokemon well
anyway aside from that what I'm trying
to say is that it's just so normal in
today's society
and then what's crazy is that as we get
older as these uh as people who are not
Muslims get older
they start to look at it as not as like
oh I'm gonna go trick-or-treating I'm
gonna go get some candy and stuff like
that but more so let's throw a party
let's get wasted and let's make it a
Halloween party and let's all dressed up
for this party
yeah people do that for St Patrick's Day
you know yeah it's always an excuse bro
they use all these things all these
holidays all this stuff that just uses
an excuse so they can drink and they can
get wasted and they can forget basically
how trashed their life is and maybe
their life is good bro so maybe they're
just trying to like feel something
though maybe they're trying to feel
something yeah it's sad really bro and
this is a message to all the parents out
there all the Muslims that are trying to
hold tight to the Rope of Allah
maybe you already celebrated Halloween
this year even though it's the 31st
technically maybe you already got the
candy maybe you already got these
decorations set up you know I'm not this
is not I'm not coming at you guys don't
worry but maybe you already did just ask
yourself like you don't still have to go
through with it you can still take these
things down you don't have to celebrate
it you don't like no one's forcing you
I know you kids might say something I
know you might be like oh we're the only
house in the neighborhood without these
you know pumpkins and without these
skeletons and all this isn't that weird
listen bro
Islam began as something strange and
will indeed return to something strange
So Glad Tidings to The Strangers
this is a Hadith authening Hadith by the
prophet saws so ask yourself like at the
end of the day
let's say let's just say their judgment
you're going to be held accountable by
Allah alas you hey you know you knew it
was what I'm you saw this video or you
knew we should at least stay away from
it why did you still insist on sending
your kids trick-or-treating because you
don't want to hurt their feelings
why did you still have these decorations
up because you didn't want to seem weird
what do you think anything you say will
be justifiable
or do you think it's just huge on appeal
and and self-confirm your own decision
that you know what I'm gonna put Society
Antonia and normalized Pagan festivals
over Islam
like I genuinely ask you this bro
because I'm I'm practicing what I preach
bro
not to air my sins but I celebrated
birthdays most of my life just because I
did it bro and then when I found out
it's it links back to these devilish
Pagan you know rituals I don't want to
celebrate birthdays I told people around
me I don't do birthdays anymore
oh but not even a kick no
oh let's go off no you know there's no
need to do it like why you know what I
mean like birthdays it just seems like a
weird way to like make someone just
narcissistic and just you know idolize
them for like a whole day they're
getting validation for nothing just for
being born what even out of Islam this
doesn't make sense but Halloween bro
you're dressing up as the shayathin and
Jin
I don't know bro I don't know yeah
people who don't want to do it because
they don't want others to
basically like
say what they what you said where it's
like oh but like oh it's everyone's
doing it oh but like just a cake oh but
it's just something that everyone does
is like bro like number one
if you can do this for the sake of Allah
then you really gotta reassess
like your dean and just your religion as
a whole because you're choosing the
affirmation or not affirmation you're
choosing the social acceptance of the
validation rule exactly the acceptance
the validation from people
versus from the Creator like these are
people that were also created so they're
also imperfect like you and you're
seeking the validation and then for for
adults who have kids like actual parents
if they don't want to like make their
kids feel bad like are you serious
you can't you can't take your kid crying
and being upset just for a little bit
like are you really that
I don't want to see it but you know
exactly what I'm talking about like as
it come to this point you know parents
say I love my kids too much to not
celebrate their birthday
but I'd rather them go to the Hellfire
that's not what they're wrong that's not
what let me let me tell you something
bro let me tell you something I love my
nieces I love them to death bro
and you know what my mom calls me up and
then she's like oh did you know it was
uh
one of your niece's birthday
and I'm like oh really when was it she's
like oh it was two three days ago how
could you forget I was like Mom you know
I don't celebrate birthdays
she's like oh you should still call her
up and like tell her happy birthday I'm
like no I told you I do not celebrate
birthdays
and like kept going on but I finally
understood like I'm not I don't do this
like this is not something that I
celebrate
I talk to my niece I asked her how her
day was I asked her if she's having a
good time if she's enjoying herself ask
her what she wants to do ask her what's
going on in school stuff like this
but why do I need to treat her
differently on one day and then treat
her just kind of just regular like so
and so for the rest of the year why not
treat her good every single day why not
reach out to her every single day and
see how she's doing
you know and it's slime
kids guys and girls every day I was
waiting for that bro I was waiting for
that yeah
every day is Mother's Day bro in Islam
ain't that right
every day is Father's day every day is
be the best Muslim that you can and or
at least try to they you know we don't
need a specific Pagan day bro what are
you guys gonna realize like every single
reason that you look at it if you want
to look at it as a pagan thing bro it's
obvious don't do it if you want to look
at it just logically like Angel saying
it doesn't make sense why would you make
that one day if you're looking at it
from societally just financially it's a
billion dollar industry bro they need
Valentine's day bro they need
Valentine's Day they need they need you
to go out and buy these things and like
bro it's crazy I went grocery shopping a
week ago it still hasn't even been
Halloween they already got stuff for
Christmas already
already bro it's not it we're like two
months away from Christmas bro oh bro
have you seen the Thanksgiving stuff yet
no we already had Canadian Thanksgiving
like a few weeks ago really so y'all
have Thanksgiving before America yeah we
always have it before you guys yeah
that's crazy Black Friday Cyber Monday
everything that's the stupidest thing
bro it's I I don't even we don't even
need to Waffle anymore bro stay tuned
Insha'Allah for Sunday 12 p.m Eastern
Standard Time ex-christian subscriber
who has now accepted Islam
um young Don couldn't
but young Dom did best believe that
Dominic and this brother's name is also
Dominic so we got two Dominics
alhamdulillah subscribers that have
accepted Islam young down where you at
with this being said see you guys Sunday
inshallah